so in the last video we showed you how
we transferred the water from the well
stream into
the tote and in today's video we're
going to show you how we get that water
out of the tote in in the garden beds so
hope you enjoy this video
[Music]
alright so you saw
how we set up the
the transfer pump the main pump that
pumps to the tote
and now i'm going to show you
how we take that water in the tote and
then
pump it onto
all of these crops over here
so this pumping station just like the
other pumping station
also runs off of a solar panel
so another 100 watt ranology panel
and that is wired
to a
charge controller
i'm going to show you
so there's my charge controller this is
a rinology one
we have bought two
and this one's the waterproof one the
other one we had before was not
waterproof and didn't work out correctly
[Music]
and then this
rinology charge controller
there's the negative and the plus for
the solar and on the back of your panel
you've got two terminals a negative and
a positive
[Music]
so that is how
that's wired to the charge controller
so now the power from the sun is going
from this solar panel into the charge
controller
and then to this battery system here
and how that's possible is there's a
plus and a negative here
where the battery goes
and you can see there's a positive and a
negative terminal on my battery
okay and then
this battery is how we're getting power
from that pump so here's the pump
so it's a sea flow pump
it's a water pressure pump
it's a 12 volt pump every this is a 12
volt system
and it produces about 5.5 gallons per
minute
and the flow is great
[Music]
so all you have to do to wire this pump
to
your battery
is
this is an old extension cord wire we
just cut it
we took the black and the white wire
put the white on the black
out terminal and the black on the red
terminal
these are your plus and your minus that
come off this battery
and then you can see it just goes and
goes and goes
and then here's my terminals
my negative
my plus here
my negative here and all we're doing is
we're taking a
bolt
[Music]
on the other end of
on the other end of the
extension cord we've got that same
uh black and white wire
the black goes in the
positive side
what we do is we take our nut here
and we put the nut
[Music]
over the terminal
right nice and tight
same thing we do over here
and then this turns on
this is your inlet pump here
so this is connected inside
of the tote
and that's pulling the water out of the
tote
through the pump but it's got to go
through this filter first let's take
this off
[Music]
okay
so there's your filter
see what sort of stuff we got in
here pretty nasty in there
probably time for a cleaning
so then it gets filtered
so then it goes through this
this filter here
into the pump and then your outlet side
and then the outlet is the garden hose
so i'm going to show you right now where
this goes to
now let's go
over to
follow the cord here
here it is
[Music]
[Applause]
there you go
you can see the pressure
is real nice
[Music]
no sort of delays in the pressure
and all we're doing is just watering
and this is how we water all of our beds
we hand water it
next year we will not be hand watering
next year we're going to try to switch
over to a
easier method for watering such as
irrigation
i know our first year and we hand
watered everything are
are we crazy i feel like we are
so pretty simple setup
you know that's how we're doing
everything with the solar powered
uh pumping station
you saw the other solar panel on the
transfer pump now you're seeing the
second station here next to the tote
and then now you're seeing all the water
that's in the tote get out of the tote
and end up in those garden beds so
hope you enjoyed this hopefully you
learned a little something
make sure to like this video if you
thought it was cool subscribe to our
channel give this video a little like
and uh
drop us a comment let us know maybe we
can help you out alright we'll see on
the next one bye
[Music]
you